so  [Music]  so  [Music]  can you handle more amazing news  i asked to be forgiven  [Music]  knowing the life that i've been living  we've both done terrible things in our  lives but everybody deserves a second  chance  i believe that you can be the version of  yourself that you want to be  i need a purpose forgiveness is  something that has to be earned it's  like that line in shoshenko redemption  get rich or die trying  if i don't do this i don't live  i have to do this to live  when i met mr cousino i was a lost soul  on my own didn't just teach me how to be  a better actor taught me how to be a  human being please help you save my life  you look good  so do you  i'm like legit nervous we don't hear  from you two hours we'll all take  cyanide bills what job babies  you